[Music]
[Music]
okay
welcome to the press conference
following the eastern partnership summit
we have a translation into many
languages so please tune in also in
russian by the way
most importantly we have just issued the
join declaration on our council webpage
and i invite you to read it we're going
to send you the link via signal as well
and i please give the floor first to
president michelle
merci merci beaucoup
madam president thank you
thank you charles
indeed i'm also glad that we had
finally the the opportunity to have a
physical meeting with our eastern
partners
because the current geopolitical
situation really demands it and indeed
we were discussing the current
challenges but also our the future of
our partnership and i can pick up where
you just left indeed there was an empty
chair in the room
and
i hope that this chair will soon be
filled by a legitimate democratically
elected belarusian leader
we all know that the belarusian regime
represses its own people
it instrumentalizes migrants putting
their lives at risk
and it is launching in parallel a hybrid
attack against the european union
you know that we responded to this
attack rapidly forcefully and in all
unity we introduced sanctions
we coordinated with our partners mainly
the united states canada and the united
kingdom
we prepared the black listing of
transport companies involved in the
smuggling of migrants
we increased our financial support to
latvia lithuania and poland on border
management
we're working with the united nations
agencies to support
the people trapped at the border and we
reached out to countries of origin and
transit in particular iraq to stop the
smuggling
it was good to see
a consensus among us the 27 member
states and the five eastern partners we
unanimously condemn lukaszenko's
behavior and we all stand with the
belarusian people
indeed the second topic was our shared
concern about the russian military
buildup along ukraine's eastern border
we are calling on russia to de-escalate
and refrain from any further aggressive
acts
we assured ukraine of our steadfast
support and commitment to its
sovereignty
and to its territorial integrity
and there should indeed be no doubt the
european union will respond firmly
to any further aggression against
ukraine
the third topic we have been discussing
was the cooperation and in particular
the joint fight against the pandemic
the european union has shared 13 million
doses of vaccine with our eastern
partner and more is to come
the commission has just signed a 35
million a
euro agreement with a polish development
bank
it will allow team europe as a whole to
step up the delivery of vaccines to the
eastern partnership
and we are also ready to provide
vaccines to the people of belarus
we have set aside vaccine doses and we
are right now looking into ways of
delivering them to the belarus people as
quickly as possible
but beyond covet we also support our
partners deal with other pressing
challenges
just before the summit we signed an
emergency support package for moldova
of 60 million euros as you know moldova
faces a severe gas supply crisis
and with this program we help reduce the
impact
of rising gas prices on the most
vulnerable people in moldova
and finally we've been talking about the
deepening cooperation with our partners
across the board
today we've launched a new more
ambitious phase
in our eastern partnership
a new agenda to help us
in our joint work of recovery and reform
underpinned by significant investment
indeed as charles said as a part of our
overall 300 billion euro global gateway
initiative
the economic and investment plan for the
region the eastern partnership could
trigger 17 billion euros of investment
for our eastern partners
there are very interesting impressive
projects in the pipeline for example
making buildings in moldova more energy
efficient
or to expanding high-speed internet to
rural georgia or to rolling out fiber
optic cable under the black sea just to
name a few
so we invited our eastern partners to
get on board
and to work with us on building new
links with us in the shared region thank
you
thank you
madam president we'll first take a few
questions
uh remotely and we'll start with
christian christian to have the ifp
foreign
is
so indeed there are sanctions against
russia in place
and
therefore they are for the actual
situation but indeed
we have been tasked as a commission by
the european council in summer to
prepare different options
in case that further aggression will
occur
so we have done our
homework we have done the preparation
so that we could respond
to further aggression which we hope will
not take place
the format of
negotiating
is very clear
after the annexation of crimea by russia
there has been established the normandy
format
where germany and france are moderators
and observers
and the conflicting parties ukraine and
russia
are dealing with in this format so i
think this is the format for that
conflict
thank you next question is for rickards
from a radio free europe picard you have
the flow
hello uh i'm going to continue with sort
of a similar question to my colleague mr
spielman i wonder actually if
it actually is possible for the european
union
to adopt proactive as opposed to
reactive sanction or does it need to
have to be sort of evidence-based so
russia needs to move before and secondly
um i think it's a third declaration
eastern partnership declaration in a row
now where you acknowledge the european
aspiration of the three associated
countries it's the same uh language all
the time essentially for the last three
summits
do you guys have any ambitions
considering you still have probably one
or two more summits as presidents to
move beyond that to be perhaps a bit
more ambitious when it comes to moldova
georgia and ukraine
yeah for the for the first version of
the imperial trifer we have given a very
clear a very clear answer we can only
repeat what what has been said uh just
before we have sentence in place point
one uh we are ready to take sanctions
additional sanctions if it is needed and
we will assess what will be the
situation and we have expressed and we
will reiterate tomorrow a very firm
position uh we support the intellectual
the total integrity of ukraine we
support the sovereignty of ukraine we
are coordinating with our like-minded
partners with our allies and we will
decide based on what will happen and we
hope that there will be no further
escalation and no further adoration
there is a normal d format in order to
implement
the missed agreement and there are
channels of
communication channels of that that are
needed in order to avoid any further
escalation
so indeed our very first call is on
russia to de-escalate but we are also
prepared for any
increasing aggression from russia's side
as i said sanctions are in place
those sanctions could be tightened but
of course they are also sanctions
prepared
that
are additional and coming on top on all
the different fields you might think of
and the message is very clear
should russia take further aggressive
actions against ukraine
the costs will be severe and the
consequences serious and this is the
clear messaging at
this time
the second part of your question
we have an association agreement and a
deep and controversial comprehensive
free trade agreement
both have a lot of scope still to be
explored in the width and in the depth
so there's a lot of added value we can
still develop
between us
and the trio countries and this is
exactly the job which we are doing right
now
on top comes
the economic and investment
plan which is completely new which is a
completely added value of 17 billion
euros with very interesting pro projects
so this is new and that's what we have
discussed today
i'll take one last question from the
room
alina from belsat please
uh hello
is european union ready to show its
strength and close that loopholes in the
sanctions against the regime of
alexander lukashenka
which about asks svelanikanovska asked
you in her statement in european
parliament
it's about loopholes and sanctions which
regime is using
to avoid the sanctions
so loopholes but should not be in
sanctions and of course we are willing
to look into if those
are there
this is an ongoing process
and
therefore the sanctions are very clear
uh to have an effect
but i also think that in the belarus
situation we saw how effective we can be
when the european union acts united and
rapidly what we exactly did so it was
visible that the outrage to the
countries of origin origin did really
work
that the immediate sanctions the united
posture towards belarus did have quite
an effect so that many thousand migrants
now are back safe in their the countries
of origin
and
the sanctions in place are effective
thank you madam president and mr
president
please read our joint declaration which
has been published on our website thank
you and see you tomorrow
foreign
you